in march of 1963 dr maurice hilleman was
woken up one night by his five-year-old
daughter
she was complaining of a sore throat so
hilleman looked her over
and determined she had the mumps
unable to sleep he was struck with an
idea he swabbed her throat for a sample
drove to the lab and got to work
four years later his mum's vaccine was
approved
it was the fastest a vaccine had ever
been developed
until now new vaccine against
coronavirus and it's incredible how
quickly this vaccine and others have
been developed this was done
in record time this is extraordinary
this is the fastest vaccine development
in us history
in 2020 vaccines for covet 19 have
shattered previous records
going from development to approval in a
matter of months
that speed was driven by billions of
dollars in a global effort
but in some cases it was also because of
a breakthrough in vaccine technology
decades in the making something that
could shrink this timeline going forward
and change how we make vaccines all
together
vaccines teach your immune system how to
respond to a threat
and traditionally there have been four
ways to do this
the two most common types of vaccines
work by exposing you to a weakened or
dead version of a virus or bacteria
the weakened virus won't make you sick
but it will teach your body how to fight
the real thing
if you're exposed to it later on this is
how the measles and annual flu vaccines
work
another less common type of vaccine does
a similar thing but uses an
inert version of a toxin instead of a
virus
the most well-known version of this is
probably the tetanus shot
this fourth type of vaccine works a
little differently because it only uses
a small part of the virus instead of the
whole thing
common examples of this would be the
hepatitis b vaccine or the hpv vaccine
some of the new covid19 vaccines also
rely on these traditional methods
for example one covid19 vaccine
currently in trials
uses this fourth method it only uses one
part
of the sars cov2 virus known as the
spike protein
[Music]
that spike protein is what allows the
coronavirus to enter your cells when
injected into your body on its own
it's harmless but your body will still
recognize it as a foreign threat and
launch an immune response to fight it
off
which is enough to teach your body how
to fight the whole virus
but isolating and preparing that spike
protein for a vaccine
is a process researchers first had to
modify it
then multiply it a lot and then
assemble the vaccine itself in a lab in
fact one thing that all
four of these types of vaccines have in
common is that they all require growing
and transporting large amounts of live
pathogens
in a lab and that takes a lot of time
a vaccine goes through many steps before
it can be approved
but before anything else it has to be
developed
and working with live pathogens makes
that process a lot longer
on average it takes five to ten years
for a vaccine to reach fda approval in
the united states
most covid19 vaccines have gotten
through this process a lot faster by
overlapping the different phases of
human trials
and starting the manufacturing early but
some vaccines have also found a
groundbreaking way to speed up this
first section
by shifting some of the work out of the
lab and into your body
[Music]
nearly every function in the human body
is carried out by proteins
so our cells are constantly
manufacturing them
to do that they make a single stranded
copy of dna
that copy is called messenger rna or
mrna each strand of mrna holds the
information on how to make one type of
protein
the cell reads the mrna follows the
instructions
and makes a protein and that's where
these two new types of vaccines come in
they contain instructions researchers
who developed
these new types of vaccines called mrna
vaccines started with the genetic
sequence of the virus
they also decided to focus on the spike
protein we talked about earlier
but instead of assembling and purifying
that protein in the lab
they identified the part of the genetic
sequence that creates it
and then took a much faster route by
synthesizing mrna
and using that as the vaccine which
saved months of time and money
once inside the body the cell reads the
mrna and begins to make harmless spike
proteins of its own
from there your body's immune system
recognizes the foreign threat and sounds
the alarm
this is how the new kovid 19 vaccines
from pfizer and biointec and moderna
work
but the main drawback with an mrna
vaccine is that mrna
breaks down very easily it has to be
delivered inside a protective fatty
barrier
and kept ultra cold which isn't super
ideal for a vaccine that needs to reach
all areas of the globe
another effective new to consumer kind
of vaccine works similarly
but uses dna instead of mrna which is
much more stable
the covid19 vaccines from astrazeneca
and johnson and johnson
are this type it doesn't require the
ultracold conditions
but it does have its own drawbacks to
get the dna
into your cells researchers use a
harmless virus as a carrier
but over time your body will build
resistance to that
virus which means future doses using
this carrier
will become less and less effective and
the carrier will need to be updated
but in terms of efficacy cost and speed
these two new types of vaccines have
broken records
these new vaccines are a groundbreaking
way to elicit an immune response
and while they'll have a big impact on
how we fight covid19
their real impact is just beginning
a vaccine that delivers specific
instructions to your body
opens up a whole new world of vaccine
technologies and disease treatments for
things like cancer
or hiv finding the vaccine was a turning
point for the pandemic
but the pandemic might also be a turning
point
for vaccines
[Music]
you